certain technological breakthroughs have
a way of making our lives seem more like
science fiction than reality think about
the first time you ever used a
smartphone or saw somebody use
Microsoft's Xbox Kinect all of the
sudden the future was happening kind of
right now these giant leaps have already
changed the way we work and communicate
the next step if a few startups have
anything to say about it is going to be
how we take care of our bodies we soon
may be able to diagnose ourselves using
tiny sensors and the computing power
that's already in our hands one company
called scanadu is developing a handheld
sensor that you will hold to your
forehead to get your temperature your
heart rate your blood oxygen level and
other data points the sensor will then
send all of that data via bluetooth to
your smartphone which can share the data
with you or email it to your doctor
another company cell scope has developed
a mobile accessory called the cotto
which turns your phone's camera into a
sort of ear scope put the odo in your
kids ear send the video to your kids
doctor and you may be able to get that
ear infection diagnosis and more
importantly that antibiotic prescription
without even leaving home a third outfit
mo basant has developed a
smartphone-based ultrasound machine it
costs less than eight thousand dollars a
standard ultrasound rig will run you
well into the six figures already it's
being used in developing nations to
provide more accurate diagnosis now
there are some skeptics out there
medical devices are infinitely
complicated they scream you can just
pull a little sensor
and accurate data they implore and in
some cases they may be right these
products are works in progress but the
improvement seem to be inevitable think
about it this way ten years ago we
barely knew what a smart phone was and
now we're talking about driverless cars
if you look at the history of the future
one thing seems clear it's happening